m
dans le match plein d'émotion lundi 5
septembre la seule équipe réunionnaise
de cécifoot du football jouée par des
déficients visuels rencontre pour la
première fois deux équipes de métropole
et parmi eux les champions de france en
titre
des test matches qui viennent
récompenser deux ans d'entraînement
intense
ouais on part de rien on va arriver en
fait à à quelque chose de grandiose de
fer en mesure de garantir la rencontre
avec la meilleure équipe française de
cécifoot mais les réunionnais à rude
épreuve
contact intensité face à eux trois
anciens joueurs demi finaliste des jeux
paralympiques de 2011
alors le match tourne à l'avantagé des
champions de france au coup de sifflet
final 1 à 0 les réunionnais ont perdu
avec honneur nous ont donné une belle
leçon parce qu'il y avait ça jouer quoi
ça joue au foot pour moi c'était un
régal de jouer contre eux collectivement
tactiquement techniquement on était
inférieurs et physiquement est inférieur
à ce qu'on a vu la différence de niveau
on a vu où il faut travailler et voilà
on va travailler là-dessus pour
s'améliorer
moi j'ai la chance aussi de les voir
évoluer j'ai vu j'ai vu des gars qui
sont arrivés avec la peur au ventre
savait pas comment courir comment se
déplacer et là je vois des mecs qui
commence à courir avec un ballon qui
commence à penser stratégie de jeu il ya
vraiment une dynamique s'est mis en
place s'est mise en place et qui permet
à assez jeune aveugle de pratiquer un
sport qu'ils aiment surmonter les
obstacles se dépasser c'est une marque
de fabrique de cécifoot 9 7 4
deux jours avant la rencontre sportive
l'équipe fait une autre rencontre
amicale avec nassimah dindar la
présidente du conseil départemental a
donné ville aux rêves de l'association
réunionnaise
partir aux jeux paralympiques au brésil
à rio avec une halte parisienne le
département les accompagnent et je les
félicite d'abord avant même d'y aller
c'était un projet humain de rencontres
richesse humaine et la petit séjour à
paris ils sont à l'abri tic de la
réunion à paris ils vont même manger et
goûter supprimant réunionnais comme quoi
le créole pays
robinson un voyage parisien remplie de
belles découvertes
ce midi marine goyer la gymnaste natif
de saint benoît quatrième à la poutre
aux derniers jo de cet été est venue
donner un avant goût de l'ambiance
olympique c'était bien c'était grand
gradins ça crée beaucoup
l'escale parisienne touche à sa fin mais
l'aventuré continue direction roissy
pour enregistrer les bagages l'avion
atterrit dans quelques heures
rio de janeiro au programme donne l
envie de soulever des montagnes aux
élèves du lycée français de rio se
confronter aux experts brésiliens du
cécifoot et bien sûr faire vibrer le
stade maracana l'ouverture des jeux
paralympiques jeu je vais pouvoir avoir
la possibilité d'assister à la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux paralympiques
voilà ça n'arrive pas tout le temps ça
n'arrive pas tous les jours
j'avoue concrètement que décrire ce
moment là c'est c'est tout c'est
absolument impossible à le faire et
aussi bien là ces aspects culturels donc
c'est à dire si le changement de regard
sur soi le projet mais c'est aussi sur
le changement noda par rapport aux
autres parce qu'on disait que c'était
pas possible que des personnes aveugles
plus jouer au foot alors que c'était
aussi pas possible que les joueurs
puissent aller au brésil
donc on l'a fait on aura aussi d'autres
projets qui vont venir justement que
vont concrétiser notre rêve impossible
car les projets se bousculent
après avoir initié les mauriciens au
cécifoot les réunionnais veulent
rapprocher les océans et lorgne sur les
antilles
un voyage est prévu en décembre prochain
mais pour l'heure le brésil est dans
toutes les têtes
le rêve n'est plus très loin
on